the Joe Rogan experience because people
aren't tested out here by climate yeah
and the East Coast they're tested by
climate yeah yep that winter comes
that's snowy wind comes you gotta
[ __ ] ride
you got to winterize your car ya got to
get snow tires look I don't know about
that 350 tornadoes last week where ya
heard about in the Midwest
wherever Tornado Alley cuz [ __ ] ya know
they got framed up yeah that was like
Ohio and where else Kentucky I think it
bunched handing out roses here he got
hit hard yeah man
I mean I don't know if that's really
because of climate change there those
are ramping up but if they've ramped up
in unprecedented levels like that and it
becomes impossible to live in Ohio or
Kentucky or anywhere with this tornadoes
you imagine how nuts that is if we find
out that the center of the country
it's just tornado like a tornado bowling
area filled with tornadoes Florida
you're just dodging hurricanes most of
the year basically lucky if Oh happen
where you are yeah you get lucky yeah
you're a dick sticking out into the
ocean and it's right where all the
tornadoes get forms or all the
Hurricanes get warm they it's like
warmer waters right here we go
we'll get started right here yeah [ __ ]
hurricanes I've been in a little baby
hurricane before and I was living in
Boston which is pretty far away from the
ocean in terms of where my house was and
it's still it was like wow yeah and I
was a little baby one it was nothing by
the time it got to us it was nothing I
lived in Japan for two years and there's
gonna have some crazy [ __ ] earthquakes
over there oh really why you were there
yeah they had earthquakes and typhoons
you saw both yeah [ __ ] yeah oh yeah like
was an earthquake like bad you've never
been in one here yeah I've got a baby
one like a 5.5 row like I'm talking
about whole room just shaking like it's
like a ride or a universal light because
you see [ __ ] moving it's like damn is
this really happening
and this [ __ ] happens bro like the
earthquakes over there are insane Wow me
yup and they get some crazy rain like
when the typhoons calling that [ __ ] gets
really violent yeah yeah the Japanese
are you know they they hold it down
what were you doing living over there my
parents are military my mom was in there
for a little bit but then she got out
and my dad was in there he got out but
remarried so that's how I stayed in the
military thing was my stepmom and I
would move we would live on base you
know I mean for like two years or
whatever and then I would look back on
my mom Wow what was it like living in
Japan it was crazy like it was fun I
lived in the late 90s
so it was like when technology was first
changing like music was just now going
into mp3s and [ __ ] like that so there
was that Pokemon was really popular over
there yeah it was fun like just being a
kid like running around [ __ ] it up in
Japan it was cool man
that's funny as hell that's a and an
interesting little extra level to your
brain right yeah you grew up those two
years in a completely different kind of
culture yeah so have a different
understanding of what's possible right
100% I think that's so big for kids man
show them [ __ ] yeah yeah how about a lot
for sure it was cool it has to right as
far as your perspective uh-huh and
speeding around I've only been a Tokyo
for a few days only once where I was
like this is one of the trickiest place
I've ever been in my life phrase so
interesting it was crazy living there
was wild like no TV like regular TV they
don't got any like American TV stations
so for two years I was just like haha
disconnected yeah like I didn't have
[ __ ] yeah and this is so this is before
Netflix and everything too right the
more YouTube mm-hmm Wow
yeah that's amazing yeah it was probably
really good for you know I sucked I
couldn't watch wrestling but it was
really good for your brain no no I need
it I mean my entertainment
I need to be a part of the world hahaha
I couldn't buy all the CDs and [ __ ] that
everybody was listening to it was it was
wack did you learn to speak Japanese
that's a little bit yeah yeah baby
Japanese just to get around the [ __ ] but
I forgot it though you forgot it all not
all of it well it'll come back if I like
yeah I mean you run me through it but I
can't sit here and say no Japanese words
how hard was it to learn it wasn't
difficult no no no it's not difficult
reading it is difficult
yeah because they have symbols or
characters so it's like one character
means like three of our words um Wow
yeah yeah and then they have like three
different styles of writing it too so
it's like we have print and cursive they
don't know re different ones oh that
sounds so annoying yeah it's weird
on one hand you don't want it to go away
cuz it's an ancient language on another
hand you like can't clean this up
simplify this ship I honestly think they
got it down pat you know they'll do you
want us to have a [ __ ] know that [ __ ]
you know I'm saying like at the end of
the day that I will learn English if we
want to but if you want to learn
Japanese it's gonna be difficult bro I
want to learn some Asian language
because I by reading like Twitter
messages hmm from you know how much the
many more characters they had yeah they
can write books yeah 140 characters like
how many words is that though yeah you
know that's a lot of [ __ ] words if
it's 280 so I mean 280 are those Asian
with this Chinese or Japanese those
little symbols it's a lot of talking man
yeah and it's hard to put like the
ingredients on [ __ ] oh yeah
do they have symbols for numbers or just
use numbers I forgot what the numbers
look like
I think it's symbols really yeah yeah
like I don't imagine that is like 1 2 &
oh wow right yeah you know I never even
thought of that
yeah what does what what is uh let's go
with Japanese does Japanese does the
Japanese language have symbols that
represent numbers like you would write
the letter
the letters th r ee for three like that
like you would write three or you'd be
the number three mm-hmm do they have
that in Japanese not cuz Japanese like
each each knee son she there's different
different whole different words for it
so it's like one is Ichi
so this symbol where have you spelled
that in Japanese I'm starting to kinda
remember what it looks like now do you
think if you could move back there right
now you just get right back and explain
things after a while sure David Lee Roth
moved there and hail in the lead sir
yeah he moved down there and took kendo
lessons mmm he lived there for like more
than a year I would probably appreciate
it more now as an adult you think so
yeah yeah cuz that's the kid you kind of
just want to run wild and do everything
that's right on TV but oh he must be an
annoyed you're stuck there it was kind
of weird you know what I mean it was 13
like when I go crazy it was fun for a
little while but yeah you want to go
back home and [ __ ] yeah I mean of course
but as an adult I feel like I would I
would benefit a lot more from it
[Applause]